une place pour les rêves mais les rêves
à leur place
Robert Desnos
bon je sais pas où je vais avec ça mais
je trouvais ça stylée de commencer par
une citation donc
on rêve d'un rêve
bon ça c'est du Frédéric Beigbeder c'est
moins stylé tout de suite bon de toute
façon on arrête avec les citations
aujourd'hui on va parler des rêves et
surtout du contrôle qu'on peut avoir sur
ses rêves
intéressant mais juste avant j'ai un
petit truc à vous dire cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par Emma vous les connaissez
maintenant ils avaient sponso ma vidéo
sur la paralysie du sommeil et sur les
bullshit sur le sommeil et comme d'hab
j'ai un cadeau pour vous perso j'avais
déjà la couette j'avais déjà les
oreillers et le surmatelas à mémoire de
forme et maintenant en plus j'ai le
linge de lit j'ai l'impression de dormir
sur un nuage c'est pas dur j'ai jamais
dormi sur un nuage dans la vraie vie je
pense que c'est physiquement impossible
mais si c'était possible je suis sûr que
ça ressemblerait à ça
[Musique]
alors si vous n'avez pas vu les deux
vidéos précédentes déjà allez les voir
s'il vous plaît mais je vais aussi vous
expliquer ce qu'ils font chez Emma chez
Emma Yvan des matelas des accessoires et
du linge de lit des matelas bon vous
connaissez les leurs ils sont garanties
10 ans et leur matelas hybride il a été
élu meilleur choix UFC Que Choisir en
2021 et le Emma original et le plus
vendu en France depuis deux ans les
accessoires de lit bah comme je vous ai
dit c'est des sur-matelas des oreillers
des couettes des draps des taies etc
tout ça fabriquer avec un seul but
améliorer la qualité de votre sommeil et
c'est pas compliqué vous faites votre
choix sur le site vous passez commande
et vous recevez tout ça en 72 heures la
livraison elle est gratuite et le retour
aussi si vous n'êtes pas convaincu oui
parce que vous avez s'ennuie d'essai
sans risque donc vous avez trois mois
pour envoyer tout ça gratuitement si ça
vous va pas et ce cadeau alors
ça arrive je vous offre moins 10% sur
tout le site avec le code DTC et
attention 10% de réduction en plus des
réductions et des promos déjà en cours
le code il est valable si moi donc vous
avez jusqu'à mars 203 vous avez toutes
les infos et le lien dans la description
de la vidéo vous avez juste à cliquer
dessus à faire votre choix à passer
votre commande et hop c'est parti les
rêves à quoi ça sert
pas de ça qu'on va parler aujourd'hui
mais une prochaine fois si ça vous
intéresse bon je recommence les rêves il
y a deux trucs que tout le monde sait
sur les rêves 1 dans les rêves c'est
souvent n'importe quoi à ce moment je
fais toujours le même rêve nage dans la
scène tout d'un coup j'avais un rat
alors j'étouffe et puis je coule et en
bas il y a des huit elle m'attrape les
chevilles alors je vomirai sur les
huîtres l'oreille attaque les huîtres je
remonte à la surface pour une pénis de
la tête et là je me réveille et deux il
y a ceux qui s'en souviennent et ceux
qui sont souvenaient jamais c'est vrai
ça mes rêves c'est vraiment nimp en
général comment ça se fait ça ah
intéressant ça bon
qu'on va parler aujourd'hui mais une
prochaine fois si ça vous intéresse bon
je recommence c'est vrai ça mes rêves
c'est vraiment nain attendez c'est
chelou est-ce qu'on est dans un rêve là
comment on peut être sûr d'ailleurs bon
bref non seulement on rêve souvent c'est
nimpe mais en plus on s'en rappelle pas
toujours et dans les deux cas que ce
soit au niveau du contenu des rêves ou
du fait de s'en rappeler ou pas on a
l'impression qu'on maîtrise rien alors
qu'en fait si on peut enfin on peut
essayer en tout cas alors déjà pour
qu'on soit bien d'accord parce que je
sens qu'il y en a deux trois là qui vont
me dire le contraire oui toi là avec le
t-shirt là avec le col un petit peu
c'est toi que je parle essayez pas de me
la faire parce que à moi on me l'a fait
pas ok je joue pas au courant tu vas pas
gagner avec moi donc pour que tout le
monde soit bien d'accord tout le monde
rêve oui même toi arrête bon pour tout
vous dire ok il y a des gens qui rêvent
pas mais alors c'est vraiment une toute
toute petite minorité des gens et quand
ça arrive c'est à cause de maladie comme
le syndrome de Sharko vilbrandt par
exemple qui est une forme d'AV c'est
extrêmement rare donc bon alors si tout
le monde rêve pourquoi il y en a qui
s'en souviennent et d'autre part avant
de répondre à cette question que vous
vous posiez pas mais que vous vous posez
maintenant je vais répondre à une autre
question que vous vous posiez pas non
plus et que vous vous posez toujours pas
parce que je n'ai pas encore posé
moi-même je suis réel revenez
voilà donc la fameuse question tout le
monde rêve mais est-ce que tout le monde
rêve toutes les nuits la réponse est oui
très vraisemblablement en l'état des
connaissances actuelles de la science en
tout cas tout le monde rêve toutes les
nuits et même dans toutes ces phases de
sommeil même si tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que c'est pendant les
phases de sommeil paradoxal qu'on rêve
le plus et que nos rêves sont les plus
élaborés donc que c'est de cela qu'on se
rappelle le plus on se réveillant je
vous refais pas le topo sur les
différentes phases de sommeil vous
retournez voir la vidéo j'en parle je
vous mets tout dans la description tout
le monde rêve toutes les nuits et
pourtant on se rappelle en moyenne que
de 1 à 3 rêves par semaine pour les
grands rêveurs ça monte jusqu'à 5 par
semaine et pour les petits rêveurs c'est
pas plus de deux par mois et puis pour
d'autres jamais bon mais du coup si tout
le monde rêve toutes les nuits pourquoi
il y en a qui s'en souviennent et
d'autres quasiment jamais et ben on a
plusieurs pistes d'abord les grands
rêveurs ils auraient une organisation
cérébrale particulière quand ils dorment
mais aussi quand ils sont réveillés en
gros le cerveau des grands rêveurs
marche pas exactement de la même façon
que celui des petits rêveurs mais est-ce
que ça ça leur fait faire plus de rêve
donc ils s'en rappellent au moins un
quand il se réveille ou est-ce qu'il se
rappelle juste plus facilement de leurs
rêves difficile à dire mais par contre
il y a un truc qu'on sait c'est que
notre mémoire est fonctionne pas quand
on dort seulement quand on est arrivé
quand on dort les zones du cerveau qui
sont responsables de l'encodage des
souvenirs dans la mémoire si vous voulez
et ben elle fonctionne pas ou alors très
peu du coup si on dort d'une traite on a
beau rêvé plusieurs fois ça imprime pas
par contre il y a plusieurs études qui
ont montré que si on réveille des gens
pendant une phase de sommeil paradoxal
80 à 90% d'entre eux vont être capables
de raconter un rêve et 50 à 75% si on
les réveille dans une autre phase de
sommeil d'ailleurs les chercheuses et
les chercheurs et se sont rendus compte
que ceux qui se souviennent le plus de
leurs rêves c'est ceux qui ont le plus
de face de réveil ou de micro réveils
pendant la nuit au total ils ont 30
minutes de temps de réveil alors que
pour les petits rêveurs c'est moitié
moins et les chercheurs toujours ils
pensent que c'est tout simplement parce
que les grands rêveurs ont le sommeil
plus léger pour exacts ils ont remarqué
qu'il y a une zone précise du cerveau
qui est plus active chez eux la jonction
temporo pariétal juste là entre le lobe
temporal et le lobe pariétal et cette
zone ça serait celle qui nous rend plus
attentif aux stimulation extérieure
comme le bruit par exemple ce serait
aussi la zone qui est responsable de
l'empathie pas de ça qu'on parle mais je
vous le donne quand même en tout cas
cette zone là elle met les grands
rêveurs plus facilement en situation de
micro réveil et du coup pendant ce
temps-là leur mémoire elle peut
enregistrer les rêves qui viennent de
faire mais alors comment on fait si on
est un petit rêveur parce que je vous ai
dit que tout le monde rêvait toutes les
nuits mais ce que je vous ai pas dit
c'est qu'on estime qu'on fait en moyenne
4 à 6 rêves par nuit et qui sont de plus
en plus longs au fur et à mesure que la
nuit avance chaque rêve durerait environ
5 à 30 minutes parfois plus ce qui
donnerait environ une à deux heures de
rêve par nuit attention tout ça c'est
juste des estimations mais quand même
c'est comme si on allait voir un film au
ciné toutes les nuits un film qu'on a
écrit nous-mêmes en plus c'est vrai que
c'est dommage de pas s'en souvenir alors
on va voir un peu comment on peut faire
avec
conseils pour se souvenir de ses rêves
préparez-vous alors comment on fait ça
et bah en se conditionnant le soir en
allant vous coucher répétez vous
plusieurs fois que vous voulez vous
rappelez de vos rêves que vous devez
vous rappeler de vos rêves que c'est
important etc augmenter votre vigilance
par rapport à vos rêves on est d'accord
que ça a pas modifier fondamentalement
le fonctionnement de votre cerveau que
ça va pas vous rendre forcément plus
réactif au stimulation extérieure
n'empêche que si vous vous réveillez
pendant la nuit et que vous avez ça en
tête vous oublierez sûrement moins
rapidement le rêve que vous avez fait et
vous aurez plus de chances de vous en
rappeler le lendemain matin vous
réveillant réveillez-vous la nuit alors
franchement je veux pas vous mentir là
c'est plus une expérience que je vous
propose de tenter c'est pas un truc
prouvé scientifiquement clairement mais
voilà ce que je me dis si on se réveille
la nuit on a plus de chance de se
rappeler de ce dont on vient de rêver
vous vous souvenez on a dit ça tout à
l'heure donc si vous mettez un réveil
pendant la nuit ou plusieurs même
logiquement vous augmentez vos chances
de vous rappeler de vos rêves
franchement je sais pas essayer et dites
moi si ça marche par contre franchement
si vous êtes du genre à avoir beaucoup
de mal à vous rendormir oubliez ça
direct ça vous flinguer vos nuits moi ne
veut pas être responsable de ça par
contre si vous vous rendormez facilement
le plaisir de se dire qu'il reste
plusieurs heures à dormir c'est cadeau
pour être tout à fait honnête il y a une
théorie autour d'un neurotransmetteur
qui s'appelle la noradrénaline en gros
notre taux de noradrénaline il est très
bas pendant le sommeil paradoxal et ce
serait pour ça qu'on rêverait beaucoup
et qu'on s'en souviendrait plus
facilement et par contre la sonnerie du
réveil ça provoquerait un pic de
noradrénaline et du coup ça nous
empêcherait de nous en souvenir bon
après ça ça reste juste une théorie donc
moi je dis on peut se tenter quand même
notre petite expérience entre nous
prenez des notes donc si vous vous
réveillez exprès ou pas vous avez de
grandes chances de vous souvenir d'un
rêve vous vous en souvenez sur le coup
mais après si vous vous rendez il y a
quand même des chances que le lendemain
matin en vous réveillant vous ayez tout
oublié donc bah prenez des notes vocale
ou écrite du coup prévoyez ce qu'il faut
sur votre table de chevet pour le moment
où vous allez vous réveiller vous avez
rien à perdre au pire vous vous marrez
bien le lendemain en check en tout ça je
pense prenez du temps au réveil bon là
pour le coup vous êtes réveillé vu que
c'est le matin donc si vous avez rêvé
juste avant vous devriez être capable de
vous en souvenir SAU aussi la théorie du
réveil et de la noradrénaline est vrai
et surtout sauf si vous sautez direct du
lit pour vous jeter sur une boisson
chaude ou que sais-je avant de vous
lever et de mettre la machine en route
pour la journée prenez-vous 5 minutes au
calme pour essayer de vous rappeler de
vos rêves ou peut-être d'un autre que
vous avez fait pendant la nuit juste
avant un micro réveil on sait jamais
prêté attention à vos rêves oui alors ça
a l'air un peu Niel mais essayez de
garder en tête l'intérêt que vous portez
à vos rêves et restez vigilant parfois
comme ça entre la poire et le dessert il
y a des petits bouts de souvenirs de
rêve qui peuvent remonter dans ces cas
là faites comme le matin prenez un petit
peu le temps et laissez venir essayer de
vous rappeler ça peut revenir si vous
vous posez un peu voilà donc faites bien
tout ça et au bout d'un moment c'est
possible que votre cerveau prenne
l'habitude d'être plus attentif à vos
rêves et que du coup vous vous en
souveniez plus facilement bon et si pour
une raison X ou Y vous préféreriez ne
pas trop vous rappeler de vos rêves
il faudrait faire exactement l'inverse
imagine oui j'imagine parce que je vous
cache pas que c'est pas très court comme
demande donc ce serait sûrement un truc
comme ce conditionner en mode les rêves
c'est pas important et diminuer ces
phases de réveil pendant la nuit en
diminuant les fameuses stimulations
extérieures déjà par exemple c'est à
dire tout ce qui est susceptible de nous
réveiller mettre des bouchons d'oreilles
fermez les volets fermez les rideaux
virer le téléphone de la chambre virer
tous les objets qui font du bruit ou qui
ont une petite lumière baisser le
chauffage etc etc et puis se coucher le
plus détendu possible pour faire une
nuit d'une traite sans se réveiller en
gros les mêmes conseils que pour bien
dormir tout simplement on a déjà parlé
vous vous souvenez alors par contre si
vous pensiez à vous la coller pour bien
dormir comme un parpaing oubliez tout de
suite avec l'alcool on a un sommeil de
mauvaise qualité avec plus de face de
réveil et plus de cauchemars donc si
c'est ça que vous vouliez éviter c'est
triple raté en fait bon ok là on a
essentiellement parlé de comment se
souvenir ou oublier les rêves qu'on fait
ce qui est une forme de contrôle mais
est-ce on peut avoir le contrôle sur le
contenu de nos rêves est-ce qu'on peut
décider de quoi on rêve
est-ce que vous connaissez les rêves
lucides j'en avais parlé dans ma vidéo
sur la paralysie du sommeil un rêve
lucide c'est une espèce d'expérience au
cours de laquelle on sait qu'on est en
train de rêver et du coup on arrive à
choisir ce dont on va rêver j'avoue
c'est d'entendre voilà donc les gens qui
font des rêves lucides non seulement ils
sont conscients qui sont en train de
rêver mais en plus il y en a certains
qui peuvent choisir des éléments du
scénario de leurs rêves pas tous mais il
y en a alors comment on peut être sûr de
ça bah il y a plusieurs équipes de
chercheurs qui ont fait une étude
spécifiquement là dessus ils ont donné
un truc à faire à des gens pendant leurs
rêves puis ils ont attendu qui
s'endorment et pour être sûr qu'ils
étaient bien conscients qu'ils étaient
en train de rêver et qu'ils avaient bien
fait ce qu'on leur avait demandé ils ont
mis au point un code en gros quand ils
avaient réussi la mission qu'on leur
avait confié dans leurs rêves il devait
bouger leur globes oculaire d'une
certaine façon et contracter certains
muscles de leur visage pour prévenir les
chercheurs et puis pour répondre à leurs
questions en dormant donc donc on peut
communiquer avec l'extérieur pendant
qu'on rêve et on peut aussi influencer
le contenu de nos rêves ok mais bon tout
le monde est pas capable de faire des
rêves lucides et ben pas tout le monde
mais sans doute plus que vous le pensez
les gens ont étudié ça sont pas
complètement d'accord sur les chiffres
très précisément mais on estime que plus
de la moitié des adultes fait au moins
un rêve lucide dans sa vie et que
presque un quart en fait au moins deux
par mois et que dans un tiers des cas
non seulement ils auraient bien
conscience qu'ils sont en train de rêver
mais en plus ils arriveraient à
contrôler le contenu de leurs rêves voir
à se réveiller sur commande mais pour ça
il faudrait être dans une forme de
sommeil paradoxal un peu particulier et
il y a plusieurs équipes qui travaillent
là-dessus pour trouver un moyen
d'arriver à cet état et donc espérer
pouvoir contrôler ses rêves et il y a
plusieurs pistes il y a une sorte de
d'entraînement si vous voulez des
exercices mentaux à faire et qui
augmenteraient les chances de faire des
rêves lucides il y a aussi des
techniques qui consistent à stimuler les
gens pendant leur phase de sommeil
paradoxal alors c'est pas facile à faire
à la maison j'avoue il y a aussi
certains médicaments comme la
galantamine par exemple qui est utilisée
pour traiter certaines formes de et qui
aurait fait preuve de leur efficacité et
puis il y a des chercheurs allemands qui
ont réussi à multiplier par 10 le nombre
de rêves lucides fait par les gens qui
participaient à leur expérience alors
comment ils ont fait ça et bah ils ont
remarqué que les fameuses ondes
cérébrales des grands rêveurs celles qui
sont un petit peu différentes du sommeil
paradoxal habituel et ben elles sont
entre 25 et 40 Hz donc ils ont mis des
électrodes sur le crâne des volontaires
et ils leur ont envoyé des impulsions
électriques de ces fréquences là pendant
leur sommeil paradoxal et hop dix fois
plus de rêve lucides imaginez un peu ça
veut dire qu'on pourrait créer une
machine pour contrôler nos rêves
non je rigole mais imaginez quand même
[Musique]
oui ça existe des chercheurs du MIT donc
aux États-Unis cette fois ont mis au
point dormir
l'état hypnagogique c'est-à-dire cet
état de conscience un petit peu
particulier qui arrive au moment de la
phase d'endormissement quand on est déjà
un petit peu endormi mais encore un
petit peu conscient quand même c'est une
sorte de gant avec des capteurs qui vont
repérer l'entrée dans cet état en
surveillant l'activité cardiaque et
musculaire par exemple et quand c'est
fait va envoyer des stimulations grâce à
l'autre partie de la machine ce
haut-parleur qui envoie des messages
vocaux d'abord un premier message
et puis quand c'est le bon moment un
autre qui demande aux dormeur à quoi il
est en train de penser et qui lui
rappelle qu'il faut qu'il prenne tout ça
plusieurs fois au moment opportun repéré
par le gant et au final pendant les
essais plus de 65% des gens ont
effectivement rêvé à un arbre bon ça a
été testé que sur une cinquantaine de
personnes dans l'état actuel des choses
ça peut pas être commercialisé mais le
jour où ce sera bon je suis à peu près
sûr que ce sera pas très compliqué de
trouver des gens pour lancer le truc
pour aller un peu plus loin
tout ça c'est juste quelques exemples
mais les rêves ça fascine tout le monde
donc on n'a pas fini d'entendre parler
d'expérience plus ou moins scientifiques
pour essayer de les contrôler
voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui si
vous avez testé les trucs que je vous ai
donné revenez me dire si ça a marché
dans les commentaires ou sur les réseaux
sociaux vous avez tout ça dans la
description on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]